翻訳: Ryohei Hanaoka
校正: Koichiro YODA
それでは まず初めにですね
頭の体操からいきたいと思います
「何かいな？」と思うかも
しれませんけども
こちらポテトサラダ んー
えー これはですね
［ポテトサラダ 250円］
実は 私のビジネスのお仲間で
福島県はいわき市でね
回転寿司をやられている
出村さんという方が
考えたアイデアなんですけども
まあ 回転寿司ですから
いろんなサイドメニューが
あるわけですよね
その中で悩み事がありました
それが何かと言ったら
ポテトサラダ
売れへんのですよね
卵使っている
マヨネーズ使っている
だからまあ 作ったその日か
まあ翌日くらいには
売り切れて欲しいんですけども
こうメニュー表にね
「ポーン」と置いてるだけでは
お客さんの食指は動けへんと
さあ そこで出村さん
どういうふうにしたかというと
このポテトサラダの前に ね
このポテトサラダの前に
枕詞を付けて
売り上げをドーンと
上げることができた
「さあ ここでみなさんが
出村さんの立場だったら
どんな枕詞をつけて
売り上げ上げようとしますか？」
という頭の体操です
ちょっと頭の中で２～３個
思い描いてみてください
［○○なポテトサラダ 250円］
色んな言葉が出てきたんや
ないかなと思うんですが
実はこれね こんなふうにして
売り上げを上げたんですね
「お店の看板娘 みよちゃんが
作ったポテトサラダ 250円」と
面白いですよね
すごくユニークで
普通のポテトサラダから
何かね こう魅力的な
豊かなものが伝わったと
そういうふうになっていくと
思うんですよね
で まあおかげさまでね
こんな感じでね
企業さんの商品とかサービスとか
それをどういうふうに伝えればね
より広く伝わるか
そういう伝え方コーチ
最近ではね 学校の先生とか
あるいはその プレゼンテーションの
能力を上げたいとか
そういった人たちにも
指導させていただく
機会がずいぶん増えまして
今からですね ８年前ですわ
2010年ね
大阪は「天満天神繁昌亭」
という所で
落語家入門講座
というのがありました
そこでね プロの噺家さんに
お月謝を払って
稽古をつけていただくという
そこに入門いたしました
喋りのスキルを伸ばしたい
あるいはね ここぞというときに
笑いをどーんと取れるような
そんな人間になりたいと思いまして
入門しまして 半年が経ちまして
ちょうど修了式ですわ
当時ね 上方落語協会
会長でいらっしゃいました
桂三枝 現六代 文枝師匠で
ございますけども
その師匠からお名前を頂いて
「八軒家 けん市」という名前でね
アマチュアですけども
素人ですけども
ボランティアで
地元尼崎を中心に
落語をさしてもらってるんですね
で まあ 初めの２年ぐらいはね
身内とか知り合い相手に
落語をすることが多かったんで
まあ こんな私の
へたくそな話でも
みんな にこやかに
聞いてくれてたんですが
思い出しますね
2012年2月25日ですよ
今でも思い出しますね
全く縁もゆかりもない所からね
落語の依頼を受けたんですよ
私ね 気合入ってましてね
もう 小躍りして喜んだ
「よっしゃこれは何がなんでもね
笑わせたろやないか！」言うて
当日の衣装がこんな感じでね
紋付羽織でドーン！と
いったわけですよ
落語をやる場所を高い座と書いて
高座と言うんですけどね
その高座にビャーッ！と行ってね
バッ！と座ってね
「よっしゃ！笑わしたるでえ！」
と意気揚々と喋り始めたんです
そうすると 最初のうちはね
お爺ちゃん お婆ちゃん
30～40人が
「いや～ にいちゃん
よう来てくれたなあ」いう感じで
にこやかにこっちを
見てくれたんですけども
これが３分経ち
５分経ちなってきたら
どうなってきたかというと
だんだん みんな
そわそわ そわそわし始めた
中にはね 時計を見るような人も
出てきたりして
これね 話の半ばの
10分くらいになってくると
半分くらいの人が舟をこぎ始めた
話の終わりの18分になると
なんと 私を呼んだ
主催者ですら
みんな夢の中に
入ってしまったという
これはね 私 屈辱的でしたね
「噺家殺すのに刃物はいらぬ
あくび三つで即死する」
てなことを言いますけどもね
私 即死どころやございませんよ
こんなんね
もう 何回輪廻転生せな
あかんかいうぐらい
それぐらいの
屈辱的なことが起きた
そのとき思いましたね
「どうやったらあの時 お爺ちゃん
お婆ちゃん起こすことができたんやろ？
どうやったら笑わすことが
できたんやろ？」
色々考えて 色んな人に
意見を聞いて 色んな本読んだ
そのときに 私 学生時代
演劇をやってたんで
つかこうへいさんというね
劇作家の方が書かれた文章が
ちょっと頭の中にパーン！と
蘇ってきたんです
そのとき つかさん
こんなふうに言うてるんですね
たとえばね 男と女の
海での別れのシーンがあると
ところがね 男と女の
別れを支えるような
そんな寒い海なんて
あるわけがないと
どこに行ったってね
日本海行ったって
アラスカ行ったって
南極行ったってあるわけがないと
でも これがお芝居で
演劇だったらね
役者がめっちゃ上手で
こうポケットに手
突っ込みながら遠く見て
「寒い海ですね」
ってこういうふうに呟けばね
波の音なんかなくても
十分寒い海になる
南極以上の二人の悲しい
海が出来上がる
これが観客のね
想像力を駆り立てて
豊饒な世界に
繋がるんだということを
まあ 書いてあったわけです
「なるほど そういうことか！」と
「私がお爺ちゃんお婆ちゃんを
起こすことができなかったのは
相手の想像力に働きかけることが
できひんかったから
なるほどなあ」と
そういうふうに思ったんですが
さあここで つかさんの言う
イメージの豊饒さ
つまり 相手の
想像力をかりたてる
イメージの豊饒さは 一体
どこから来るんかということを
ちょっと考え始めたわけです
そんなときに 一番有名な
俳句の句があるんですけども
これに出会ったわけですね
「柿食えば 鐘が鳴るなり 法隆寺」
まあ 正岡子規が詠んだ句の中でも
一番有名な句やと言われてますけども
これね いつも私
よう聞くんですよ
みなさんにね
日本全国で聞くんですけども
さあ この正岡子規の句 ね
「１日24時間の中で
何時ぐらいに詠んだ句ですか？」と
「１日24時間 何時ぐらいですか？」
と聞きます
そうすると80％から90％の人は
「ああ 夕方ですか？」
というふうに答えるんですね
中にはね「真夜中ですか？」とか
「お三時ですか？」とか まぁまぁ
「明け方ですか？」というふうに
言われる方もたまにはいらっしゃいます
たまにはいるけども
８割から９割の人は
「５時か６時くらいの夕方ですか？」
というふうに言われるんですよ
そういうとき
私 聞くんですね
「あ！なるほど！夕方ですか？
ほう！そしたらこれね
どこに夕方って書いてますか？」
って聞くんです
書いてないんですよ
書いてないにも関わらず
今 みなさんの頭の中には
こうね 夕日が落ちていって
法隆寺がシルエットで映ってて
そこにカラスが飛んでって
ゴーンと鳴ってるような
なんかそういう
ノスタルジックなイメージを
頭の中に描いたんじゃないですか？
100％ 全然伝えていないのに
なぜ そんな豊饒なイメージが
湧いて来るのか
そう 私が考えた結論は
こちらなんですね
実は 100％伝えるんじゃなくて
この20％の余白を残してあげること
これが実は豊かさを生み出す
源泉やないかなと
そんなふうに思い出したんですね
じゃあ 具体的にこれ
どういうふうなことになってるか
ちょっとお話をしたいと思いますが
今からお見せするのは『崇徳院』という
落語のネタの一節なんです
主人公の若旦那さんが
町の中で偶然出会った女性
それに一目惚れしたんですね
そのときにこの女性を形容するのが
こんなふうな言い方なんです
「お年の頃なら 十七 八
お供を四 五人連れた それはそれは美しい
水も垂れるような綺麗なお方
世には うつやかな人も
あるもんやなぁと見とれてた」と
これが『崇徳院』の
一節なんですけども
あるいは男性を説明するときに
こんな感じですね
「旦さんは 背のスラっと高い
色の浅黒い 眼のパッチリとした
苦味の走ったいい男で」と
これは『悋気の独楽』という
ネタの一節です
今 男女の容姿の話をしました
たとえば 女性を形容するときに
「北川景子さんみたいな
シュッとして美人なんやで」
あるいは「八千草薫さんみたいにな
ものごっつい上品でな
別嬪さんやったんやで」
というふうに言われても
まあね 北川景子さんや八千草薫さんを
知っている人からすれば
「はあ！なるほど！
そんな美人で別嬪がおったんかいな！」
というふうになりますけども
これ知らない人からすると
「え？どんだけ美人で
別嬪なんかようわからん！
わからん！わからん！」と言って
想像力は そこでストップ
してしまうわけですよね
あるいは 男性を
形容するときでもね
「○○さんに似て
ものごっついイケメンで
格好良くて ハンサムやねん！」
と言われても
それ聞いた本人が
○○さんのこと嫌いやったら
「えー？！あんなんに
似てんの？最悪！」
みたいなことに
なってしまうわけです
だから 物事をぼかして
伝えるということが
実は 重要なスキルに
なってくるんですが
これは日常生活でも
使えるわけなんですね
たとえば 雨が降ってると
しましょうね
天気予報を見てた
「明日は１時間に100ミリの
雨が降るでしょう」と言われて
「ほお！なるほど！
そんなすごい雨が降るんか！」と
イメージできるのは
これは 気象予報士ぐらいしか
ないわけですよね
我々からすると 「うーん？
いまいちようわからんな！」
まあ確かに この100ミリという
数字は事実を伝えている
正確無比なのかもしれませんけども
でもそこにね 雨のたたずまいとか
あるいは梅雨の匂いとか
そういうものは一切感じることが
できないわけなんですよね
だからこれをどういうふうに
言い換えるかというと たとえば
「滝のようにゴーゴーと
雨が降り出したで！」とか
あるいは「車軸を流すような雨が
ビャーッ！と降ってきた！」と
そんなふうに言われる方が
我々のイマジネーション
想像力を駆り立てるわけです
たとえば 心臓の音でもそうですよね
「心臓が今ドキドキしてんねん」
と言われるのと
「心臓がバクバクやねん！」
どっちが緊張感ありますか？
そらバクバクの方じゃないですか
あるいは お歌の世界でも
同じことです
「兎追ひし 彼の山
小鮒釣りし 彼の川」
有名な『ふるさと』の
一つの部分ですけども
これね 彼の山 彼の川ってね
ぼかしてくれてるから
我々は ノスタルジックな
イメージをすることができる
これ たとえばね
具体的な山 川
入れたらどうなるかって
たとえば「兎追ひし
甲山」 とかね
「小鮒釣りし 神崎川」
とか言われても
なんか 僕ら神戸とか
京阪神の人間やから
なんとなく「ああ なるほどなぁ」と
わかりますけども
これ 他所の人からすると
「どこの山 川やねん！」というふうに
なってしまうわけですよね
だから「彼の山 彼の川」で
ぼかすことによって
我々が幼いときに見た原風景
山 川がそこに
フラッシュバックして
イメージが豊饒になっていくと
でね 今から一つね
物事を100％伝えたとしても
伝わらない例というのを
今からお見せしますわ
どういったことかと言うと
こういう文章があるとしますね
「時は 2000年以上前
標高843メートルの山の麓
70歳の古希を超えたであろう
夫婦がいました
ある５月の13時頃
のどかな田園風景の中
川の幅300メートルの川岸で
おばあさんが一人 洗濯をしていると
はるか川上
580メートルほど前の所から
直径60センチの大きな桃が
時速５キロメートル弱の
スピードで流れてきたー！」
というのをたった一言で表すと
「どんぶらこ」になる
（笑）
すごいですよね 今 私あれね
読み上げたら250文字あるんですよ
その250文字がたったの
５文字で表現できるんです
みなさんよく考えてみてください
今までの人生の中でね
川で洗濯をしてて ひゅっと見たら
向こうから桃が流れてきて
それをキャッチして
家に持って帰った経験ある人？
いないんです！世界中
どこ探してもいないんですよ！
でも 我々はね 経験したことがないのに
このどんぶらこを聞いただけで
あれだけのことを
無意識的 意識的に関わらず
バーっと思い描くんですよ
だからね 桃太郎は
世界的な名作って言われてるけども
海外からも評価が高い
そしてね このどんぶらこ
擬音語 擬態語なんですけども
海外の人からするとね
「日本語すごいよ！半端ねえよ！」
ってなるんですよ
それだけ評価が高いんです
じゃあ そんだけ評価が高いんやったら
私 ちょっとね 調べてみました
この「どんぶらこ」ね
Google先生に聞いてみたんですよ
一体 英語でどんなふうに
訳されるんやと
そうするとみなさん
驚きの結果になりましたよ
刮目してください！
こうなりました！
（音声）（英語）ドンブラコ
［どんぶらこ Don Braco］
ドンブラコ
そのまんまやないかと
思うんですけどもね
ですからね オノマトペ
まあ 擬音語 擬態語
これね 実は5,500種類あると
言われています
すごい数ですよね 日本語の中で
だからね 私はこのね 日本語って
ほんと素晴らしいなあと思うんです
でもね 時々こういうこと
言われたことないですか？
「日本人ってね
自己主張 下手くそやな」とか
「日本人ってなかなか
自己主張せえへんなあ」って
そんなふうに聞いたこと
一度や二度はあると思います
でもね 私から言わしたらね
これ自己主張せえへんのやない
もっと言うと自己主張
できへんのやないんですよ
相手の想像力を慮るがゆえにね
相手の中にあるものを
大切にしようとそういった姿勢が
そういうふうな空白を生み
そして世界にも類を見ないほどの
膨大な擬音語 擬態語
オノマトペを作り出して
それらを利用して
我々の先祖というのは
いつの時代でも豊かな人間関係
豊かな地域社会
あるいは国や 豊かな世界を
作り上げてきたんやないかなって
そんなふうに思い始めたんです
だからね 相手の心を
つかむためには
あるいは聞き手のハートを
射止めるためには
相手の中に豊かなものを
植え付けてあげる
その植え付ける土壌が
実は 20％の空白
なんやないかなって
そんなふうに思います
「でもなぁ 俺 喋り下手やしなぁ」
そんなふうに思われた方も
中にはいるかもしれません
あるいはね 今まで何かを伝えようとして
上手くいかなかった
それがトラウマになって
尻込みしてしまう人とか
後ずさりしてしまう人とか
諦めてきた人とか
中にはいらっしゃるかも
しれないんですよ
でも 大丈夫です
どういったことか
今から二つ俳句を
見ていただきます
こんな俳句ですね
「初雪や かくれおおせぬ 馬の糞」
あるいは
「つくつくぼうし つくつくぼうし
ばかりなり」と
どちらかというと これ
もっちゃりした句なんですけども
一体 これ誰が詠んだんでしょう
そう 正岡子規が詠んだんですよ
正岡子規ね 18歳から34歳のね
17年間の間に
なんと短歌と俳句合わせて４万句
４万句詠んでるんですね
残してるだけで４万ですから
ということは
書いて「こらあかん！」言うて
ポーイと捨ててしもたやつとか
頭に浮かんだけど
「こんなんあかんわ！」言うて
シュッと捨ててしまったやつとか
そんなん合わしたら
４万句どころか
何十万句 たぶん
考えたんやないかなって
そんな失敗いっぱいしてきた中で
あの「柿食えば」という
超人的な俳句が
生まれてきたんやないかなって
失敗したからそんなんが
出てきたんやないかなって
思うようになったんですね
なんでそんなことを言えるか
そうなんです 私も実は
いっぱい失敗してるんですよ
恥をさらすようですけどね
あっちこっちで失敗してます
失敗の山ですわ
でも その失敗することで
実は 挑む価値っていうのが
存在するんですね
どういったことか
一番最初に見ていただいた
みよちゃんの例
みなさん これ一体「みよちゃん
どんな人なんかな？」って
たぶん 頭の中で
描いたと思うんです
さあ これ みよちゃんに
会いに行きました
すし八に会いに行きました
「今日 みよちゃんいるの？」
「ああ ごめんなさい
今日 お休みなんです」
「今日はみよちゃんいるの？」
「ああ 今日もお休みなんです」
そう みよちゃん
いつ行ってもこれね お休み
なんで？
そう そのとおり！
実在しない人物
架空の人物なんですよ
「えー なんやこれ 架空の人物
実在せえへんのか 残念やなあ！」
と思ったかもしれませんが
でも 私がこの話を
一番最初にしたときに
みなさんの頭の中には
一人ひとりのみよちゃん像が
浮かび上がって
そのみよちゃんがいたからこそ
このポテトサラダが より魅力的な
より豊かな より豊饒な
品物に変わったんじゃないですか？
だからね 空白から豊かさってのは
生まれるんです
ね その余白が
豊饒さを生み出すんです
ですから これから先の人生
少し 少しだけでいいんで
相手にとっての20％
聞き手にとっての20％
これを意識して伝えてみませんか？
間違いなく挑む価値は
十分にあります
ありがとうございました
（拍手）